facebook afronta la que podría ser la
peor crisis de su historia francis
haugen ex trabajadora de la compañía
denunció ante el congreso de eeuu una
serie de prácticas perjudiciales para la
sociedad que la empresa pasa por alto en
prioridad de sus ganancias económicas
estoy aquí porque los productos de
facebook ponen en peligro a los niños
causan división y debilitan nuestra
democracia los líderes de la compañía
saben cómo hacer facebook e instagram
más seguros pero no harán los cambios
necesarios porque ponen sus intereses
astronómicos por encima de las personas
haug en filtro miles de documentos de la
empresa al diario wall street journal
que reveló que la compañía sabía que
instagram es perjudicial para la salud
mental de los adolescentes pero que sus
directivos no hicieron nada para
evitarlo también que durante la pandemia
la compañía no tomó medidas para reducir
la desinformación sobre las vacunas
contra el coronavirus y que ha permitido
que su algoritmo fomente el odio en su
plataforma porque está demostrado que
los comentarios agresivos crea más
visitas y hacen que las personas pasen
más tiempo en su página web la compañía
esconda intencionadamente información al
público al gobierno de eeuu y a
gobiernos de distintas partes del mundo
para hauge en el principal obstáculo
para combatir las prácticas de facebook
es el ocultismo al interior de la
empresa los documentos filtrados por
ella ahora también han llegado al
congreso y la antigua trabajadora dice
que estos son la prueba de que facebook
pone deliberadamente sus intereses
financieros por encima de los de la
sociedad